تضمن مشروع الميزانيه المقدم للمجلس
الوطني لنواب الشعب في الصين زياده في
الانفاق العسكري للبلاد بازيد من سبعه في
المئه الامر الذي سيجعله ينمو في السنه
2023 الجاريه باسرع وتيره له خلال اربع
سنوات يشير مشروع الميزانيه الى ان ذلك
الانفاق سيستحوذ على حصه اكبر في اقتصاد
البلاد في ظل توتر متصاعد بين بيجين و
واشنط
ن اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان ذاك خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما
الذي تنطوي عليه الاهميه المتصاعده
للانفاق العسكري في ميزانيات الصين في
السنوات الاخيره
والى اي مدى يمكن الربط بين استراتيجيه
الصين فيما يتعلق بالانفاق العسكري وتصاعد
التوتر بينها وبين الولايات المتحده على
خلفيه تقدم التعاون العسكري بين بيجين
وموسكو
وكيف ستتعامل واشنطن وحلفائها الغربيون مع
توجه الصين الى تعزيز انفاق العسكري وهل
في التنافس على هذا الصعيد ما سيعجل ام
يحول دون انزلاق التوتر بين الجانبين الى
المواجهه
[موسيقى]
تقول ان جيشها دفاعي ولا يمكن ان تقارن
نفقاتها العسكريه بتلك التي تخصصها
الولايات المتحده لتعزيز قدراتها العسكريه
انها الصين التي تذكر بين حين واخر انها
لا تملك سوى قاعده عسكريه واحده خارج
الحدود في جيبوتي بينما لدى واشنطن عشرات
القواعد العسكريه المنثوره في طول العالم
وعرضه مع ذلك من اصعب ان تنظر الولايات
المتحده ومعها حلف الناتو والدول الغربيه
الى بلوغ الانفاق العسكري الصيني
224 مليار دولار بعين الارتياح خاصه في
هذه المرحله التي تشهد فيها العلاقات بين
الطرفين توترا متصاعدا ينذر بحسب بعض
المراقبين بمواجهه قد تقع
رئيس الوزراء الصينيه لكاتشيانغ قال امام
البرلمان انه لا بد من تنسيق العمليات
العسكريه وبناء القدرات والاستعداد التام
للقتال
وشدد رئيس الحكومه الصينيه على ضروره
تطوير العلاقات السلميه ودفع عمليه اعاده
التوحيد السلمي مع اتخاذ خطوات حازمه لمنع
استقلال تايوان
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من فلوريدا
دكتور ديفيد سيدني نائب مساعد وزير الدفاع
الامريكي السابق لشؤون الامن القوميه في
اسيا ومن بيجيني ينضموا الينا رونج هوان
الاعلامي والباحث السياسي ومن بودابست
المحلل محلل شؤون الامنيه والدفاعيه
والباحثه المختص في شؤون الجنوب شرق اسيا
نبدا مع السيد
هو ان من الصين من بيجين تحديدا
والسؤال المطروح عن الرسائل او الاسباب
التي تدفع الصين
لزياده انفاقها العسكري وهو مسار مستمر
منذ ثلاث سنوات
اهلا هو مرحبا بكم
السبب الزياده هو بان
يعني مع النمو الاقتصادي الصيني
فسينج الى البناء والقدرات الدفاعيه التي
تتناسب مع النمو الاقتصادي الصيني
ومكانتها الدوليه وكذلك من اجل ايضا
مواجهه يعني التحديات الامنيه
المعقده في الصين
وكل هذا من اجل ان تقدم
البيئات يعني بيئه سليمه وملائم للتنميه
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
طيب عندما عندما تقول مواجهه التحديات هل
تقصد بذلك ان هناك تحديات عسكريه تواجه
الصين هل تعتبر الصين نفسها مهدده فعلا
اليوم
طبعا يعني التحديات الامنيه تشمل مثلا
هناك التحالفات العسكريه حول الصين من قبل
الولايات المتحده هناك زياده انفاق
الدفاعيه في السريعه في اليابان وكذلك
الدول الثوار وكذلك زياده الوجود العسكريه
امريكيه في منطقه اسيا والباسيفيك وكل هذه
تعتبر الصين التحديات الامنيه
طيب سيد دنس سيد ديفيد سيدني ما الغريب في
هذه الخطوه الصينيه يعني هناك
تطور في الاقتصاد الصيني زياده النمو
وايضا زياده في التحديات وحتى الدول
المجاوره للصين ايضا
ترفع من انفاقها العسكري فاين المشكله لو
قامت بذلك
الصين ورفعت انفاقها العسكري
لا تقوم فقط بزياده انفاق العسكري بشكل
قليل هي تزيد هذا الانفاق بشكل كبير في
نفس الوقت فان اقتصادها لا ليس اداءه بما
هو متوقع الصين تواجهه الكثير من التحديات
الاقتصاديه في قطاع الصحه والتعليم لكن
الصين تختار ان تقوم بزياده الانفاق على
القطاع العسكري اكثر من القطاعات
الاجتماعيه والتنميه الاقتصاديه اعتقد ان
هذه اشاره واضحه لكل من لكل العالم ان
ايران عفوا اصيل تحاول ان تزيد من قدراتها
العسكريه لكي تستخدم جيشها لكي تهدد الدول
الاخرى بالتاكيد الدول الاخرى سترد وخاصه
الدول المجاوره لها مثل مثل كوريا
واليابان وفيتنام عن طريق زياده انفاقيه
العسكري ايضا ولكن لماذا لا يكون الامر
معكوسا يعني لماذا لا
يمكن ان نقول بان الولايات المتحده تقوم
بتدريبات
عسكريه ومناورات مع كوريا الشماليه حتى مع
اليابان وبالتالي هي صاحبه اكبر انفاق
عسكري في العالم لا يقارن باي دوله اخرى
لماذا لا نقول ان الصين تقوم على رد فعل
او تقوم برد فعل اذا ذلك
اعتقد انك تعرض ربما سوء فهم
ان الولايات المتحده وحلفاء يواجهون
تحديات وهم الخيطون في حرب في
اوكرانيا وهم يدعمون اوكرانيا في صد عدائي
روسيا
الولايات المتحده ايضا تواجه تهديدا من
كوريا الشماليه بالتالي تعمل الولايات
المتحده مع قريه الجنوبيه واليابان من اجل
مواجهه التحديات التي تواجهها تلك البلدان
ودمي حلفائها الصين ليس لدي تواجه لا
تواجهها اي من هذه التحديات الصين هي التي
هي التي تمثل تهديدا وخاصه فيما يتعلق
بتايوان الولايات المتحده والصين اعتقدها
في مرحله ما ان حل قضيه يجب ان يكون
بطريقه سلميه لكن الصين قامت بشكل كبير
بزياده نشاطاتها العسكريه وتهديد تايوان
وارسال طائرات وسفن الغواصات بقربي من
الجزيره وتحدثت عن السيطره عليها بالقوه
هذه الافعال التهديديه بالتاكيد ستتطلب
ردا لذلك ساقول ان الولايات المتحده هي
دوله مختلفه عن الصين وتحترم مسؤولياتها
وايضا جيشها اكبر لكن زياده الصين
لانفاقها العسكري بطريقه تقوم بذلك بطريقه
تهدد من استقرار المنطقه
كيف تقرا
هذا الاجراء الصيني
بزياده الانفاق العسكري للسنه الثالثه على
التوالي
فه اولا شكرا للاستضافه اذا ما اردنا
تحليل الوضع السياسي
الحالي والوضع وما يحدث في العالم نحن
بحاجه الى ان نفهم الى ان الصين تراقب عن
كثب
النزاع المستمر في اوكرانيا
والصين هي واحده من البلدان التي تدرس
بعنايه مجريات النزاع في اوكرانيا فهي
تحاول بناء على ذلك تسليح نفسها وفي منطقه
المحيط الهندي
الهادئ من المهم لاي بلد في عالم السياسه
المعاصر ان يدرك ان تلك المنطقه تسمح
واحده من اكثر المناطق سخونه وهذا ما يجب
على الصين او هذا في نظر الصين على الاقل
ان عليها ان تاخذ بعين الاعتبار دورها
وقوتها في المنطقه وتاخذ ذلك على محمل
الجد وساضرب مثلا
الولايات المتحده بدات بضخ الاموال في
الفلبين
من اجل زياده التسليح هناك وكما نعلم فان
اليابان هي الاخرى تزيد من انفاقها
العسكري اذا الصين ترى نفسها
موضعه تهديد من جيرانها وخاصه في ضوء
التوتر الموجود في بحر الصين الجنوبيه او
بحر جنوب الصين وترى نفسها بانها وهي تريد
ان تصبح الدوله عالميه وقوه عالميه في
منطقه المحيط الهادئ والهندي
طيب بالاشاره هنا مشاهدينا الى ان المعهد
الدولي للبحث حول السلام في ستوكهولم قال
في تقارير له ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هي الدوله التي تخصص اكبر نفقات
عسكريه في العالم بلغت 800 مليار دولار
عام 2021 واضاف المعهد ان الصين تلي
الولايات المتحده بانفاق يعادل
293 مليار دولار تلي بجين الهند بانفاق
عسكريه فوق 76 مليار دولار فالمملكه
المتحده باكثر من 68 مليار دولار لتاتي
بعدها روسيا بقرابه 66 مليار دولار ومن
بعدها فرنسا بازيد من سته وخمسين مليار
دولار اعود الى ضيف من بيجين السيد هو
يعني علي يحق للولايات المتحده هنا ان
تنظر بعين الريبه لزياده
[موسيقى]
الانفاق العسكري الصيني في الوقت الذي
تشهد فيه ايضا نوعا من التعاون والتناغم
مع روسيا في ظل الحرب على اوكرانيا وايضا
ما تراه تهديدا
لحلفائها التقليديين في اسيا الا يحق
للولايات المتحده ذلك
اولا اريد ان اؤكد واوضح نقطه ان الصين
يعني يمكن ان نرى في تقرير قبل قليل ان
الانفاق العسكري الصيني يعني يعني فقط
يحتالوا يعني
36% من الانفاق العسكريه الامريكيه وكذلك
اذا حسبنا هذا الانفاق في الدولار
الامريكيه
فان الصين هذا العام لا يوجد زياده بل
هناك انخفاض للانفاق العسكريه
الدفاعيه
فلذلك يعني
الالتحامات
بزياده الصين لانفاكهه عسكريه يعني ليس
لها اساس من الصحافه هنا
الصين
متوسط متوسط يعني نسبه الانفاق الع في
اجماليه الناتج المحلي اقل من 1.5 هذه
المعلومات معروفه لكن بغض النظر عندما
تنظر الولايات المتحده الى هذا التعاون
والتناغم مع روسيا وهي التي تعتبر نفسها
في حرب
مع روسيا ربما بالواسطه ايضا نتيجه ما
يحصل في في اوكرانيا يعني الا يضع نوعا من
الضبابيه على موقف الصين ونوايا الصين في
هذا المجال
طبعا الموقف الصين تجاه الازمه في
اوكرانيا
دائما
ومستمرا وواضحه وهو ان الصين لن تقدم اي
مساعدات عسكريه لاوكرانيا ولا لروسيا
فالصين دائما تقف على جانب الحوار والسلام
السن تحث كل الاتراك في هذه النزاع الى
وقف اطلاق النار والعوده الى الطاولات
المفاوضات بدء المفاوضات هو ان هذه الحوار
والتفاوضك والسبيل الوحيد لانهاء هذه
الازمه
فلذلك
الالتحامات يعني
[موسيقى]
للتقديم الاسلحه لروسيا فهذا ايضا ليس لها
ادله وليس لها يعني حساسه من الصحه
فهنا
[موسيقى]
هذه الاتهامات فقط تاتي بس ان الصين لم
تدعوا خطوات الولايات المتحده لفاره
العقوبات على روسيا ولكن الصين يعني
المستقله وترى ان العقوبات وتقديم الاسلحه
لن تحول المشاكل
[موسيقى]
كيف ستتعامل مع هذا التطور اذا كانت يعني
تنظر اليه على انه موجه
ضدها وضدها حلفائها
الخطوات التي اتخذتها الصين خلال سنوات
القليله الماضيه وخاصه كما ذكر الضيف
الاخر في مجالات تسمى في بحر الصين
الجنوبي الصين قامت بعسكرته هذه المنطقه
وزعمت ان هذه المنطقه هي جزء من مياه هي
الاقليميه على الرغم من ان هنالك قرار
دوليه اثناء على ان الصين ليس لها حق
بالقيام بذلك دول مثل الفلبين اندونيسيا
وفيتنام هي ترى في الصين على تراها ترى
تحديدا لمصالحها لان الصين تزعم لها ان
لها سيطره على جزء كبير من المحيط وهي
ترسل بالمقاتلات وحاملات الطائرات
والغواصات والسفن الحربيه بشكل دوري وايضا
ما يستفزه الك الدول بالتالي فان الصين في
تلك المنطقه وكما ذكرت فيما يتعلق ايضا
بتايوان وايضا مع الهند خلال السنوات
الخمسه الماضيه كان هنالك الكثير من
المواجهات العسكريه مع القوات الهنديه
والتي ادت الى حوادث قتل بعض الافراد ايضا
لكن لم تجبني بعد سيد ديفيد لم تجبني بعد
اذا كانت كل هذه اذا كانت الصين تشكل
تهديدا لتلك الاطراف التي ذكرتها واشرت
الى حوادث معينه قد حصلت الولايات المتحده
امام هذا الواقع هل بامكانها ان تفرض شيئا
على الصين هل بامكانها ان تضع حدا للصين
مثلا كيف ستتعمل مع هذه التطورات
ان الولايات المتحده لن تتمكن من التصرف
في هذا الامر لوحدها لكن مع حلفائها مثلا
مؤخرا كان بتنشيط
المجموعات
ما تسمى بالاكواد وهي مجموعات تمكن تلك
الدول من اجل ان تعمل مع بعضها البعض من
لدعم امنها ومواجهه التحديات من الصين
مثلا يابان وكوريا الجنوبيه والولايه
المتحده قاموا بالانضمام ايضا بتعاون
عسكري يمكنهم من الدفاع عن انفسهم ضد
الصين بالتالي حول الصين الدول الاخرى
التي هي تقع على حدود الصين تحاول وتسعى
للحصول على المساعده الولايات المتحده من
اجل تعزيز امكانياتها طب هذا يجعلني اسال
السيد هنا يعني ان كان هذا
الانفاق العسكري زياده الانفاق العسكري
ونوع من سباق التسلح كما هو واضح في في
شرق اسيا هناك نوع من سباق التسلح هل يمكن
ان يؤدي ذلك الى
انزلاق الوضع نحوه مواجهه عسكريه في في
مكان ما مع وجود نقاط ساخنه عده في
المنطقه
في الحقيقه اذا ما اردنا نحلل هذا القضيه
ممكن ان نفعل ذلك
بثلاثه طلقه طبعا هناك النزاع في اوكرانيا
بسبب الغزو الروسي ايضا في منطقه المحيط
الهنديل هذه ايضا هي منطقه ساخنه تزداد
سخونه
وسباق التصلح في المنطقه اذا لدينا
مجموعتان هنا مجموعه الولايات المتحده
واليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه من جهه ولدينا
الصين وكوريا الشماليه من جهه اخرى اذا ما
استمرت هاتان المجموعتان بزياده الحضور
العسكري والانفاق العسكري والتدريبات
العسكريه هذا قد يؤدي في سياق عالمي الى
زياده سباق التسلح وزعزعه الاستقرار في
منطقه المحيط الهندي واله ادئ وقد يؤثر
ذلك على حركه التجاره في العالم اذا
اعلق على صديقي من واشنطن
انا اود ان اقول ان
الهند من وجهه نظري اجندتها في منطقه
المحيط
لا ترى الى الى موضوع
[موسيقى]
الاكواد
ترتيبا عسكريا لانها اذا ما رات اليه
كواد باعتباره حلفا عسكريا او ترتيبا
عسكريا سيؤدي هذا الى تفاقم الوضع وربما
صدام بين قوتين لذلك الكواد من وجهه نظر
الهند هي لا تتعدى الاجنده الاقتصاديه
ويمكن ان ننظر الى موضوع سباق التسلح
وعسكره المحيط الهندي والهادي كاحد اسباب
هذا الانفاق العسكري المتزايد اعود اليك
لا يمكن هنا ان تواجه الصين ضغوطا دوليه
متزايده او تجد نفسها محشوره امام مواجهه
عسكريه ربما لا تريدها اذا استمرت في هذا
النهج هل تتحسب لذلك
طبعا الصين يعني لا تشارك في اي سباقه
تسلح ممكن ان نرى يمكن ان نرى ان دور
الجوار هناك زياده كبير للانفاق العسكري
ولكن لم تعمل ذلك وهناك فقط زياده طفيفه
جدا وهذا يثبت ان الصين يعني لديها ثقه
تامه لقدرتها للدفاع عن نفسها وكذلك
للحفاظ على السلام والاستقرار في هذه
المنطقه
ترى ان هذه المنطقه اسيا والفاز هي يعني
من نفس القدوه للتنميه والتطور وليس يعني
منصه لصراع الجيول السياسيه بين الدول
الكبرى لذلك الصين لاند تدعوا الى السباق
التسلح في هذا المنطقه وكذلك لا تسعى الى
الحماله والت اقامه اي يعني مناطق نفوذه
لها مثل الولايات المتحده
السياسي شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا لضيفنا من
فلوريدا دكتور ديفيد
وزيره الدفاع الامريكيه السابق لشؤون
الامن القومي في اسيا وشكرا
المحلل المحلل الشؤون الامنيه والدفاعيه
والباحث المختص في شؤون جنوب شرق اسيا كان
معنا من بودادس
انتهت حلقتنا من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
[موسيقى]